Optimal,
minimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Familiar else move closer.
Question.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living Tissue.
I wouldn't either.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body did not get paid for that and I travel
with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important,
it will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me.
It just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world.
And here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing it in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade to 99 designs.com
forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Okay.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
I deconstruct world class performers to tease out and pull out the routines,
the habits,
the breakfast,
the favorite books,
the behaviors and so on that you can use in your own life.
Borrow from these individuals who have achieved the pinnacle of whatever their
chosen field might be,
whether that's chess,
hedge fund,
managing,
sports,
acting,
government,
you name it,
military,
it goes on and on.
And in this particular episode we have a four summit is very exciting folks and
I was very nervous about the tech in managing all of the cables and so on,
but it turned out even better than I could have possibly hoped.
It was after a workout with these people who all could kick my ass in so many
ways,
it is impossible to count.
And that is a good thing because if you are the strongest person in the room,
if you are the smartest person in the room,
you're in the wrong room.
And we have three people.
So we have first Laird Hamilton who is widely considered the greatest big wave
surfer of all time.
He is also a very innovative influencer in Modern Board Sports and surfing.
So he is considered either the creator or certainly popularizer of towing
surfing,
which allows him and now many,
many other people to surf waves bigger than ever before possible and is largely
responsible for the rebirth of standup paddleboarding.
If you've seen people stand up paddle boarding,
chances are on some level you have Laird to thank for it.
Laird has started in many serving films and was the centerpiece of riding
giants,
a documentary about big wave surfing,
which of you have not seen?
You have to see it will make your palms sweat within the first few minutes.
It's insanity.
And he's also a considered the writer of the heaviest wave of all time,
or at least at the time that surfing magazine had him on the cover.
And the only caption was,
oh my God.
So He's been a contributing editor for men's journal.
He's been on Oprah,
Charlie rose,
60 minutes,
the Ellen degeneres show.
And uh,
he's also very well known and I admire layered for this,
for using his lifestyle and his skill set to raise money for charities,
including race across America,
pipeline for a cure for cystic fibrosis,
rain catcher and muscular dystrophy,
et cetera.
He's an awesome dude.
And the only person perhaps as intimidatingly awesome is his wife Gabrielle
Reece.
Gabby has been named one of the 20 most influential women in sports and is best
known for her fantastic success in volleyball.
But she's of course also to modeling.
She's had starring roles as a trainer on the biggest loser.
And a Reese is just incredible and I've had a chance to work out with Gabby.
Uh,
she is every bit as incredible as layered and they're both about a foot taller
than I am,
but,
um,
let's not go there.
That's okay.
I feel okay in my,
my,
no mish like stature in any case.
Uh,
Gabby has also used her sort of crossover success in these different fields to
become the first female athlete to ever design a shoe for Nike.
And she now serves as a fitness expert for Yahoo health among many,
many other things.
The last person in our little Monesha for,
I don't know how to say that in French is a Brian Mackenzie.
He is the founder of crossfit and directs and the author of the New York Times
bestselling book,
unbreakable runner.
Uh,
Brian has created a lot of controversy and a used feature in the four hour body
for a lot of it by suggesting a very counterintuitive approach to distance
running,
uh,
in which he challenges high mileage,
runs high carb diets and incorporates a lot of intense strength training in some
cases.
Very brief strength training to conquer everything from five ks to ultra
marathons.
And many of you out there have used his protocol,
his sort of eight week to 12 week protocol and the four hour body to go from
running nothing to running marathons and ultra marathons in record time.
So congratulations and layered for those of you who didn't see it was also one
of my surfing coaches in the Tim Ferriss experiment.
So just check that out@itunes.com forward slash timferriss two RS and two ss.
And without further ado,
here is layered Gabby and Brian
guys,
welcome to the show.
I'm so thrilled to have you guys here.
And,
uh,
I thought that we could just start off with a description of what just happened
because I came in here this morning terrified of this workout.
And
Brian,
it's something else in mind.
And,
uh,
I came out out of the workout really exhausted,
feeling great and having done things in the workout I didn't think I was capable
of.
And as hoping layered,
maybe you could just describe the training,
all of that,
but that seems like a perfect scenario.
You know,
it was,
I was very surprised it did all those things to you.
Well,
and,
uh,
I mean,
ultimately I think it's about challenging your beliefs,
but also challenging your,
you know,
your physicality.
So,
I mean,
within that scenario of,
you know,
the things that we've done,
we've,
we're,
we're thermal regulating the heat,
the ice,
the pool,
the,
the lack of breath,
the effort of,
you know,
uh,
swimming and jumping and,
you know,
all the physical stuff.
I mean,
there's just so many things happening simultaneously.
I think it really is about just complete confusion.
Yeah.
And what I also realized,
and for those people who are not familiar with lyrics pool,
and why would you be there are stairs,
there's a staircase built into the middle of the pool so that people can walk
down.
But then you might think,
well,
wouldn't you just float up to the surface?
But you have everyone weighed down with giant dumbbells with giant,
when you sign a set of steps that brings you into the pool,
these are steps that are underwater in the middle of the poor,
correct.
Yeah,
And what I realized when it's empty,
so you can do,
so you can do your workouts when the pools out there
and,
uh,
the,
to Gabby,
you gave me some very good advice.
I just remember holding dumbbells and like your eyes don't need to be as wide
open.
I just looked like,
I dunno a cat in a corner,
I guess probably bug eyed and faster is not better.
And I was hoping maybe you could just elaborate on that.
Cause I think it's a,
it's a really interesting concept that translates not just to the workout in the
pool but to a lot of things.
Well we were just saying that earlier that it's very true to life,
um,
that it's,
it is
more about with purpose and with a,
with a calm manner at times can actually be more effective.
And so the water really exaggerates all of that and also forces you to sort of a
yield to that method.
And so really just looking around takes up oxygen.
Right?
And so,
and actually you did very well today,
so you have to give yourself some credit.
But a lot of times we were so focused and our eyes open,
like when you play land sports and you go to focus,
you do open your eyes.
It's a,
it's a focus mechanism.
Right?
Right.
But in the pool it's quite opposite where you have to relax everything that you
can relax.
So all the air goes to the places that are doing the work,
right.
Your eyes,
your jaw,
everything.
And then it's moving in a way that you're,
it's what,
what amount of oxygen are you giving up for the amount of effort you're putting
in and finding that sort of sweet spot of this,
this effort,
uh,
especially when you're not doing rec,
really heavy,
heavy weight.
Right.
And it's more about the breath holding.
Okay.
Definitely.
And I was uh,
you know Brian,
we were chatting a couple of days ago when I was doing one of my usual walks in
San Francisco and you got me very excited about the pool training obviously.
And Rick,
who we both know,
Rick Rubin,
who's been on the podcast has talked about this and you were talking about using
the mask that I now have.
Yes.
As well as this training.
And uh,
when I asked you what were most excited about these days,
one of the answers was the breath training.
And I just love to hear what you are doing with the breath training,
sort of some of the results you've seen.
A,
because it's such a fundamental aspect of all life and sports,
but,
uh,
having been exposed to like Wim Hoff and so on,
it's sort of come to the forefront of my mind,
but this is my first time ever really playing around with it.
Yeah.
Doing an exhale,
then trying to swim lengths of a pool,
which is completely different.
But yeah.
What is,
what has been,
um,
what has been your experience and how are you doing some of that training?
Um,
well I,
I first was given that training mask by a buddy of mine in Hawaii and in Kwai
Elevation Training Mask.
Yeah.
Elevation training mask.
And you know,
I,
I looked at it now,
it was a little weirded out by it,
but I,
I was,
with anything I get,
I'm like,
I'm going to screw around with it and if it makes sense for me to screw around
with it,
I'll continue to screw around with it.
If it doesn't,
I'll toss it.
Um,
and I immediately got a response out of my diaphragm.
Like when I took a breath,
you have to use your diaphragm had to use my diaphragm blue who don't have the
visual,
the mask,
I guess it looks almost like a mass gain mass could use,
right.
A bane mask for construction,
You have the ventilation correct.
Can change the amount of airflow that's permitted.
Correct.
Right,
correct.
So you can get,
their whole scheme is from like 3000 feet to 18,000 feet and you can change all
of those settings.
Laird likes to play around with a little further,
which is typical.
Um,
which is good,
you know,
so unlike him,
Hey,
I know it's very unlike him.
So anyway,
I got a,
a quick understanding of this mask and I saw something that I have seen in with
every
athlete I've really ever worked with is like when you see a spinal fault or you
see a mechanical fault,
meaning their postures,
postures off positions off.
So if I'm in,
I'm making a quarter extremity violation,
I am literally probably most likely making that fault with spinal mechanics or
extremity violation.
Of your limbs is doing something funny.
Now your limb is actually compensating for making up for the lack of stability
that's going on here.
I think of being overextended or being flex too far forward.
If I flex too far forward,
I run into a wall.
When I breathe [inaudible] breathe.
If I don't,
yeah,
I can breathe and I can,
and this showed me immediately that I could get people who did not understand
this concept,
which is a very hard thing to come by.
I mean,
we can talk about it right now and people are probably like,
okay,
whatever,
you know.
But if I put the mask on,
I immediately go to my nose.
So I'm using my nose to breathe,
which is,
yes,
you should be drawing and your breath for most of your breathing through your
nose and you're forcing that diaphragm to work.
So getting that concept down and then being introduced to Laird and Gabby
through,
uh,
my friend Kai,
um,
I came up here and it wa it was just,
it's exactly like Laird said.
It's say,
you know,
it's mass confusion were confusing and we're,
we're,
we're kind of tossing the entire nuts and bolts at you.
And then it's exactly as Gabby's explaining in the fact that it's like,
look,
you actually have to be conscious of what's really going on and controlled and
like,
hey,
where are you focused?
Where are you doing?
Are you the energy of,
Oh my God,
that facial expression is literally costing energy,
right.
That cost must you reps.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
exactly.
That's what costs you reps.
And so this sending to the other side.
Yeah.
And then all your friends see you not make it.
And this is made more sense to me in being not only somebody who was a
competitive swimmer,
somebody who's a coach,
somebody who's worked.
But I specialize in movement,
but it's,
you have to learn,
you will get efficient in that pool
very quickly.
Right.
Because all of the,
any energy leak is exaggerated.
Yes.
And just so people have a,
a visual,
once again,
the first exercise we did in the pool,
I guess I had,
I want to say,
started with 15 pound weights.
Uh,
dumbbells.
And then moved up,
but you're sort of sinking to the bottom of the pool and then doing a shoulder
press as you jump up to the surface of the pool.
And then you're bringing your arms down to your sides,
almost like you're swimming a stroke.
And that's when you got to be Jack,
like a jumping jack.
And that's when circle in a big circle.
That's when you take,
you take the breath at the top.
And so immediately I was like,
Oh,
I'm holding my breath underwater,
but I have to start exhaling as soon as I go underwater.
Otherwise I'm not going to,
I'm going to have to exhale and inhale at the top and that's what I'm going to
swallow water.
Well,
it's also going to shorten your amount of air you can get in if you have to blow
out and write reading,
which is all right.
Again,
counterintuitive costs money,
baby,
you know?
Exactly.
Cost money.
So
the learning curve was so fascinating to me because even after 10 reps or 15
apps,
I was like,
oh,
that thing that I was freaking out about.
Unrepped three or four completely unnecessary.
Right.
And then,
uh,
Gabby,
I think you mentioned this to me as I was doing one of the exercises I was even
more terrified of which was holding a dumbbell to my chest and swimming
underwater,
back and forth across box.
That's called the ammo box.
Uh,
is if you feel like you can make it a exhale a little bit,
which is so counterintuitive,
that might've been B Mac.
Uh,
but that's a trigger to your drain.
Yeah.
We'll,
we'll also give you time because you knew your brain goes,
oh,
I'm exhaling,
I'm going to be inhaling.
Right.
So the rain,
so again,
it's a little bit of a confusion.
Like you confuse yourself.
It maybe you confuse your,
your instincts,
right?
Like,
like the breath holding the exhale drill.
Once you want to breathe in,
as soon as you exhale,
you have a mechanism that's designed to breathe in,
right?
Because you have pressure on the diaphragm,
the you want to breathe in.
But once you teach the body to have to resist against that and know it's okay
that you're not going to breathe in right now cause you still have the oxygen,
then that then leads you to a new place.
And what is ned?
I have,
we've,
we've drained these glasses,
but Larry,
can you elaborate on this very potent yellow elixir?
It is good.
Ah,
I put put era my,
and wanted to take a now on,
now he is ready to climb Everest remote generated.
Yeah.
And so we were doing the input exercises and then we would do ice bath for
three,
at least three minutes minimum.
Yup.
And then about 15 minutes minimum in 20 in the hot box one,
the barrels on at two 20.
So I was about to take,
I felt like I was ready for a nap and then I had this magic concoction.
What is,
what is in this beverage?
Oh,
well that was a fresh,
fresh squeezed tumeric root.
Yeah.
And you have a whole box of this turmeric root [inaudible] let's say you can get
it at the store.
Yeah.
But fresh,
fresh squeezed tumeric root,
uh,
liquid pepper extract and then a raw honey and apple cider vinegar water of
course,
to do that was fully diluted by the way.
No,
that's uh,
that's intense.
Yeah.
But I,
but I really enjoyed it.
And you also showed me something earlier,
which is about the size of a large cat.
It is a mushroom.
What type of mushroom is this?
Yeah,
it's called the Chaga Chaga,
which is pretty uncommon.
Hard to find from an it,
from what I understand.
Yeah.
Rare but rare.
More because it's unknown,
but also its uniqueness of the habitat.
It comes from and,
and uh,
and then the ability to use it and most people just don't know about it.
So it's uh,
but it's the most powerful mushroom in the world.
They say the spores are found in the stratosphere.
They found Chaga spores like in the,
in the stratosphere while in space.
[inaudible] they only mushroom to that grows on a living.
Uh,
yes.
Yeah.
And doesn't take
from it.
It's not live in Gaza.
The parasite.
It's actually supplying the symbiotic relationship to the,
I think today sort of the theme for me has just been fear so far.
My own fear.
So I'd love to talk about that.
I just a little bit,
uh,
all three of you.
I think if they've sort of befriended fear in some ways,
but,
so Gabby,
when when you were competing or even now,
uh,
obviously world class athlete,
what was your self talk like before a big match or before a big event?
How would you prepare yourself for that?
Why?
You know,
I'm not going to answer it.
I want to preface,
I want to help you out with the,
to,
because I met this app is on a show
the extremist.
Yeah.
And she was the host when I met.
Right,
right,
right.
And she came to interview me and she'd already interviewed like 60 other people
and gun an aspect of their sport.
Oh,
got it.
For her for a matching volleyball,
like I respect that as an athlete,
but for her to go out and jump out of a plane to beat to go hang gliding on some
crazy I to do a,
you know,
uh,
a dragster bike.
I mean these are because you're going into,
I don't,
I think,
I mean you can ask her that question,
she can answer it instead of me,
but ultimately ask her the question of were what was more heavy like before a
big match that you were going to play or like get on a drag bike that you've
never been on and release the collection goes zero to 60 in a second.
No,
that's helpful.
That's very helpful.
So I feel like even thank you honey.
More of a weakling and coward than I did before.
I ask the question,
but let me,
I have to say that when you,
when you,
when you practice many hours and you dedicate a lot of time to something,
yeah,
it does have a different value.
Sure.
You know,
if I was doing MTV sports are the extremists,
there was a margin of I'm going to do the best I can.
Yeah.
And certainly,
you know,
Laird always jokes that if there's,
if there's something on the line,
then I'm very good,
like really focused.
Like if you said to me,
Hey,
get real,
let's go for a mountain bike ride and,
and we're going to go for like three hours,
just the totally rad and extreme and go downhill.
I'd be like,
I'm good.
But if you said,
hey,
there's this point in purpose and we're going to,
I would do it that.
Yeah.
So I'm a little different that way.
You need the,
the stakes are the incentive or they talked of it kind of,
and that's maybe not great actually.
I'll be honest with you.
So volleyball,
I had a different emotional attachment because I invested a lot of time and it
meant a lot to me.
Yeah.
Um,
so I,
I had a different expectation that expectation.
Right.
Going into it.
Um,
I would kind of go through a ritual that would get me into a different head
space where I was switching from,
you know,
me as a person to me the competitor.
But um,
the ritual look like,
you know,
it was sort of like the hair goes up in a ponytail and then you start putting
some block on and then they put my white clean,
my glasses.
I put those on.
It was all very thought out.
I would detach away for everyone except my teammates.
Um,
but how long did that pregame ritual?
Maybe 15,
20 minutes.
I took superstitious too.
I would never compete in the color red.
If I wore something and played badly,
I would not use that visor or hair tire pair of glasses again.
Right.
So I did have those weird things,
but I think like any athlete will tell you there's certain things that I wish I
had been better at.
Um,
it took me,
I think having children has made me less concerned with making everybody happy.
Right.
And I think even when I was competing,
I was a lot,
I was really concerned about how people felt.
Um,
so that was hard because it's hard to try to be,
oh you're trying to kick ass,
but then you're worried about how people feel so bad dynamic.
So I did have,
I would change personality,
but I,
I will truthfully say that I also,
I think I held myself back.
So coming back to the parenting comment,
so having kids has made you care less about what people think.
Well,
you straight get meaner because you have no time to people outside of your kids
or to the kids.
Also
everybody.
Okay.
Now I think,
you know,
listen,
you have less time.
And also as a woman we're taught as young girls,
hey,
be nice at some,
if you're nice girls act like this.
And so it takes a long time to get to a place to go.
Okay there I'm going to do things,
say things and believe in things that people aren't going to like and I'm going
to be okay with that.
It takes men do that so much easier and it takes women a very long time.
And if you're the only athletes I've seen that do it very easily are generally
the youngest girl with all older brothers,
they understand it's not personal much sooner than girls.
And so,
you know,
and the other thing I always say is I wasn't really groomed to be a champion
like Kerri Walsh for example.
Her whole life was groomed.
She was told at an early age are a winner.
You can when it's okay to win,
expect to win.
I fell into winning and learning to win.
And so that was another thing I had to overcome.
How did you fall into winning?
By being really tall and being decently athletic and getting into sports.
I didn't have the sort of familial support didn't at all and I,
and I was,
I was a late bloomer and all these things.
So it was all like,
well,
is it okay to win?
And like it's,
it's kind of going good.
Like it was all that weird sort of things that you had to overcome.
So I think there's a lot of things you learn in children,
put things into real perspective for you.
Age puts things into perspective and those usually happen kind of simultaneous.
Yeah.
Um,
and you again,
you have less time so you kind of cut through the crap.
Yeah.
Brian,
so you've worked with a lot of athletes,
you know,
a lot of world class coaches and you've traveled a ton.
When you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind?
Um,
I will,
these two are easily at that list and that's cause you're sitting here,
what will you ask the question?
I'm sitting in front of two people
and my wife,
um,
you know,
what are the characteristic?
Why,
why do you know?
Without knowing who they were or what the,
I knew who Laird was.
I knew who Gabby was.
Irrelevant,
towed to the situation and what I was brought into and how I met them.
And at the top of that sits happiness.
Um,
you take away the financial side of stuff.
You take away the extreme,
you take away the,
you know,
correct.
The like,
Hey,
I was at the pinnacle of sport.
Like I was,
you know,
I,
I was a world class athlete.
You take that away and you see how a dynamic is working and you see how people
are functioning and they're happy.
They're surrounded by people who are happy.
They are.
It's,
it's a,
it's an ecosystem in itself.
Um,
so I think that's,
you know,
it's easy to just say that because they're sitting right here,
because it's the truth.
You know,
I'm,
I know plenty of people like that,
but I also know plenty of people that are miserable.
Then you would say,
oh,
they're so successful.
And it's like,
hmm,
what do you consider it?
Right.
If you use the bank account maybe.
Yeah,
the big count.
Or like even like just behavior.
Yeah,
like behavior of,
uh,
like I'm threatened by you,
I'm,
I'm insecure about this stuff.
Like,
it's like,
yeah,
you got some stuff to work on still.
Yeah.
Before we get,
I,
I'm,
I'm out of this situation,
like I've got to exit from this.
It would,
it just doesn't work enough for me.
Yeah.
Like in the happiness.
Let's talk about that for a second because one thing that really struck me in
why I like hanging out with you guys also have wanted to hang out more was when,
uh,
I was filming for the Tim Ferriss experiment.
We did the surfing episode,
which was a blast.
And thank you guys both for putting up with me for that period of time.
Uh,
and I suppose putting up with me now also,
but the,
the,
the memory that comes to me when people are like,
oh,
how was it?
What was it like hanging out with them?
And I,
and it's the time at home when you were joking around with the kids and like
doing the steam baths and the,
the ice baths.
That's,
I was like,
you know,
it's not just the really,
really,
really good athletes who have maintained an unbelievable level of physical
performance.
Uh,
it's that you feel,
you seem to have a very kind of integrated life,
uh,
with as spouses and then with the kids.
Uh,
but you obviously had had some challenges growing up.
Wasn't easy.
What have you,
uh,
layered,
like how have you guys thought about parenting and what you are trying to do
differently with your kids?
Well,
I think that it's our,
you know,
I think for everyone,
you maybe want to be the parent that you didn't have or maybe you want to be the
period you think you wanted.
Right?
You know,
you also,
of course,
you know,
depending on the relationship,
your parents,
if,
if
they,
if you had an incredible one,
then you want to try to be the parent that you had.
Right?
So there was parents,
I,
you know,
some of the parents I had were,
they're going to want to be in some of the parents I had.
I,
we're parents I didn't want to be.
And so,
you know,
you try to,
you tried to do the best you can and you,
and I mean,
you go from your instincts,
you go from your heart.
I mean you,
when you really look at it,
when I,
if I look at the most important thing for me in parenting,
being parented as a young child was being loved,
I go like being loved was probably,
and if I can just,
you know,
loving your children can override a lot of wrongs.
Yeah.
How do you,
how do you
demonstrate that?
Uh,
well,
I mean that sounds like a weird question,
but do you know what I mean?
Because I think a lot of smart,
I know a lot of smart people who are just not good parents and like try,
but they're not good.
We do it different like,
so for example,
Reese,
our middle daughter who is more similar to Laird and very emotional shoe would
be going through something and
thank,
you know,
she is,
I know straight up and our younger daughter more similar to Gabby's a ruthless
killer.
True.
Anyway,
so Reese,
we'd be like upset about something and I'd be like,
well let's,
you know,
what's talk about it.
How are you feeling?
What's going on?
You know,
Reese,
I mean levered,
walk in the room,
kind of take one look at her and grab her and put her on the floor and hugger.
Right.
And so,
um,
I think one thing is we've learned as we try our best to be an allied front.
We never let the kids feel like they can wedge between us ever.
Um,
so that's very helpful.
And I think believe it or not layered is more touchy feely.
Love them.
You know,
there are also girls you,
I mean if we had some sons you might be,
maybe there might be a different,
maybe because it's male,
female pointed,
right.
Daddy's little girls in Mommy's little boy.
It just,
the nature that the dynamic,
I mean I had a mother that I had an incredible relationship with and you just
have that male female reaction just don't with you Sam attacks.
Yeah.
Two.
So I think you have that.
And then,
you know,
I make sure I understand the nuances like their favorite,
they need this certain clothing and like a lessons and then they can talk to me
about their girl stuff.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
they know I'm not going to surprise them.
Like I'm sending elusive too.
And we treat them like adults.
We've always spoken to them like adults.
We treat them like a,
like a,
like an adult.
We,
you know that,
what did they say?
Treat them like an honored guest and don't act like one,
you know,
but,
but ultimately,
you know,
we treat,
we treat them,
we take them with us when we go,
we all go together.
When we go to eat somewhere.
I mean,
we'd go to dinner parties where no one brings their kids,
but we bring our kids because our just otherwise we don't go where the people
that invite us know that,
hey,
it's the big date come.
They're coming with the family.
Yeah.
And we're tough on them.
We're tough on them.
We're,
we're in what ways are you tough on them?
I mean,
we're just like,
if they do something where that could be perceived as not using really good
judgment,
there's no like,
well honey,
me,
no,
we don't do that in this house.
It's straight up.
Like,
what are you doing?
You know?
So I think there's a direct,
we have a very direct style of parenting,
which thank goodness our children are a certain way because for me personally,
my kids are very stubborn and strong willed and everything else.
But it would be much harder for me if I had a kid that was,
that I'd have to coddle more,
uh,
because I would,
I don't know that verbiage as well.
Um,
but listen,
I've had to say,
I'm sorry many times.
That's another thing you learn as a parent.
You have to learn to say sorry because you blow it so you can,
it's sometimes you can go,
hey,
you know what,
I'm,
I am extra tired today and I,
my fuse is short and I am being unfair to you.
And I'm sorry,
like you have to learn that you're imperfect and,
and kind of opened that door up to like,
there's times that you go,
hey,
you know,
I always say to my girls,
do you feel loved enough?
You know,
because you want to know.
And they're like,
oh,
you'll come on mom.
You know,
but I think he should ask.
We'll just asking says a lot.
Right.
Even even if they like brush it off,
like I would imagine kids respect by asking them respect and also you're showing
them it's okay to not be perfect because we're not perfect either.
Right.
So we're not demanding some perfection out of them,
which is totally unobtainable.
How you can do that.
But having said that,
like right now are almost 20 year old daughter.
She doesn't love us right now.
Right.
I'm telling straight up like she doesn't,
she's not loving us right now.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
Yeah.
So it's not like,
Ooh La,
la I and it,
which interesting because Brian's comments talking about,
you know,
having that,
that that happiness or contentment or is a sign of success.
And I always said as a parent to be a successful parent would be that you could
raise a continuum and cause I don't know that many.
So if you could actually be a parent that raises a contain human good parenting.
Yeah.
And what I would have also noticed just with,
with you guys and then,
uh,
Brian and I,
it's,
I want to get your take on,
on a,
on a bunch of things,
uh,
is that you have,
you mentioned like kind of wrestling to the ground.
You have a very physical relationship with your kids and I think it's,
no,
but I,
it's like he's a very,
as someone who only recently gotten back into physical play doing stuff like
acro yoga,
it's been incredibly effective at anxiety reduction,
relaxation and just feeling grounded and connected to other people.
So I think that's also something that has struck me is just how you use
a lot of physical interaction with your kids.
Why Hawaii too?
Like,
yeah,
like if you,
if my kids are hearing you go to leave,
they're going to get up and walk you to the door and say goodbye.
In Hawaii,
when you see an Auntie or an uncle,
you give him a hug.
There's a touching component of like a tactile and all more how,
like our main thing about even animals,
right?
Yeah.
Like,
if my kid does something and I'm going to grab her arm,
right.
Or even like,
even if it's k t,
you know,
physical and play,
but just physical,
like we're in general.
Yeah.
So think that the physical is a reflection of the emotional.
Okay.
No,
because if you know,
you do yoga and it's an intense position and you're having all this stuff,
but this is for spiritual enlightenment.
This is to come to a higher level of consciousness,
but it's a physical act.
So in a way,
this physical relationship we have makes a mentally stronger shoots him
mentally,
you know,
all these things are just reflection,
these physical reflections of these emotional states.
So all of a sudden,
emotionally there are a lot more open and do new things and handle and be tough
and all that stuff.
Well,
it's like the training and the pool earlier,
it's the same,
same element of transfer.
Uh,
Brian,
you looked like you had something to say.
I do have another question.
Why I think this all adds to the,
this,
this is happiness.
This is there.
They're having fun with your kids.
Yeah.
I don't see,
there's only really a couple other people and the other person that really comes
to mind when the same way that there's a family,
like this is Kelly.
Yeah.
Start out and,
and everything.
The star,
I mean I'm a part of that family.
Like I am literally I,
I don't live there anymore.
I used to live five doors down.
Yeah.
But I go up there,
I stayed at the house,
I'm with the girls,
I helped the girls get ready.
I'll take him to school.
I'll like the whole process is this whole Auntie,
uncle,
this whole thing of being happy and are we having fun?
If you're not having fun,
what are we doing?
They seem even happier than we are sometimes.
I feel like Lauren and I are like rough around the edges a little bit.
Like,
you know,
like there's no secrets and it's kind of our,
like I feel like when I speak nationally it feels like lighter and nicer.
I envy that.
And some people like,
I'm like,
yes.
Well,
but Kelly is Kelly and but youtube is,
I,
there has been very rare that I've seen almost a,
the same type of dynamic happening where you have a husband wife combination
that is,
is that works in the dynamic that it does.
Well here,
here's a question for you.
So the two examples that you brought up.
Yes.
Right.
Kelly,
Juliet,
two of you,
they work out together.
Yeah.
Right.
And so you people say sometimes you know,
those who work out together stay together.
Do you,
can you think of anybody offhand who does not exercise together?
Spouses who are very happy in the same way?
Can you guys,
I'm just curious.
Okay.
Cause I have friends,
they function better when the,
to live their worlds and then they come together because in a way,
even though Laird and I are independent,
I think we both need that touchstone with each other.
Um,
and it isn't chicken well and isn't maybe even the training because the joke is
the only time we trained together as in the pool because it's underwater and we
can't talk because we don't train together on the land.
Like Laird is my confidant and someone that I go to to get bounce ideas off or
an a mentor in other ways,
but we don't actually train together too many,
too bossy both.
Right.
So that's the running joke like we don't,
so the pool,
it's cool because her class is too hard.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Like the joke is like we can treat in the pool because we're under the water.
We can't smack talking to John.
I know you should do it like this.
No,
I should do it like that.
You know what I'm saying?
Play volleyball.
I used to be that.
I used to be the practice dummy.
Yeah,
I would.
I would ride home in the back of the truck and the dog because we fight.
Like I would be in the back with the dogs
and I'd be driving the car.
I'm like that new new year underneath my breath and there'd be sitting there and
whether the bed,
the dogs would be looking in his face and he'd be pissed.
And my team like would win on some bad calls and he'd be like,
Oh,
you girls feel good about winning like that.
You're going to like that.
And we're like,
yeah,
like you don't get it like any way to win.
And they're just can't understand that.
So we,
to be honest,
like let's not glorify.
Yeah,
yeah.
We do things together,
but it's,
there's a lot of space.
Yeah.
Because when you,
when you days are long and when you're in years,
right?
Like we're going on 20 years,
it's like you have to find that pace.
And there's some people,
if they had nine to five jobs,
maybe they should train together.
So we have a different deal.
But the number one thing in all successful relationships,
10,000 couples,
there's only one thing that was,
that everybody had in common no matter what the dynamic,
because there's all that,
all the different dynamics.
One thing only,
what is it?
Great sex.
Oh,
that's a good call.
Good call probably.
Right.
That was probably the second.
Yeah.
The first thing,
did the man respected the woman?
Uh,
number one thing that demand,
I guarantee.
Yeah.
That Kelly respects his wife [inaudible]
take them apart limb by limb.
She has Brian,
his wife and I respect.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So that's the bright,
narrow,
those three couples right away.
Respect the man.
[inaudible] can I say one thing and I know and all those dynamics different,
like the ones that bed runner,
the,
the mass of better,
she's dominant,
he's dominant,
whatever.
But ultimately more times than not,
if,
if the woman can refrain from trying to change or mother her partner.
Yeah.
She has a greater opportunity of putting herself in a position where the guy,
I'll respect you.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's support.
That's it.
Yeah.
It's support.
A man needs support.
Yeah.
I mean I love you guys and you're all strong,
but you're very fragile.
Oh yeah.
And you need to be like supported and help you fully realize your voice.
What is it?
Cause we're expendable.
And so we have to go out and die for you at some point.
Yeah.
So we better be get it supported like the pram,
you better you better support needs because I'm going to go,
you know,
run in front of Tina,
Toronto Stars Rex for you get mowed down.
So how do you,
how do you sub best support as a woman?
How do you best support your,
uh,
your part yellow counter partner without mothering?
What's the,
and had a great education.
First and foremost,
I'll be honest with you,
I picked a partner who there was just no chance in hell,
right?
So Laird said to me the first couple of years we were together and unfortunately
his,
his mom passed away.
Um,
the second year we're together.
I had a mom and she died and he made it very clear.
So what it did is let me off the hook.
I don't need it.
No,
you don't mother me.
And so what it did is it made me switch my brain right then where,
hey,
that's off the table.
Cause women by nature,
we can't help it.
We're nurturers.
Right?
So sometimes that seeps over like,
hey honey,
that joke was kind of inappropriate.
The dinner table,
you're talking kind of loud.
It's all that.
Okay.
And then what happens is,
is we somehow,
cause the man is trying to be loving and stuff,
they pacify us and then they change all the ways we want them to and then we
don't want them.
Right?
So it's a,
it's a great thing where you just say,
Hey,
I'm going to pick a partner that I feel like our value system is similar.
We may get there very differently,
but are kind of how we line up on some of the big items are the same.
And also what you learn is the,
for example,
layered is when you're with layered,
you feel really loved.
Like when he directs that at you,
it's for real.
Right?
So,
but it's connected to I'm restless.
Um,
I needed venture,
all these other things.
So you sort of say,
you start to understand,
hey,
these things over here that make this person who they are,
I'm going to love all of it.
Right.
Um,
and
nor the fact that he talks over me and you know,
yeah.
These are small things because you have to start looking at the big things.
Yeah.
You know,
like they're doing the best they can.
They're honest.
They're,
you know,
it's like all these important things.
Right.
And you let it ride.
Oh yeah,
they're here.
That's another story.
When I was like,
am I think I was 27 right.
And Lord said to me,
I said something about,
you know,
I took things way more personal.
Of course you do.
Yeah.
And then you go,
oh yeah,
that's not my thing.
He said,
I said something in there.
It goes,
yeah,
but I'm here every night.
And in my mind I thought,
well,
Duh,
I'm here every night too.
But I didn't really know what that meant for a man to say,
Hey,
I'm going to really try to be with one woman.
Yeah.
They're giving you all,
most of what they got.
Yeah.
They give you like 80% yup.
And for a woman,
maybe she's giving you a 35.
Right.
So it's like to understand,
to like understand people's language on how they give.
Yeah.
Let's say I was very shy and I came out and I was having a very nice,
you know,
sort of conversation with you.
Maybe I'm giving you 200% because of my nature.
Exactly.
So I think it's also starting to understand who they are.
They're giving how they can give and receiving it that way.
But don't try to change them because I always tell my friends,
if you want to be with a king,
you have to treat them like a king.
And if you're always like done and do that,
there are a pile in the corner.
Exactly.
Brian,
I'm going to shift gears for a second here.
What is the,
this is going to be a jarring transition,
but that's my specialty as an interviewer.
Uh,
awkward segues your most gifted book.
What book?
And I'm going to ask you guys the same question.
What gift,
what book or books have you gifted the most other people?
Okay.
That it's probably between two.
All right.
A doubt.
A chain or um,
the,
ah,
it's Dan Millman.
Uh,
way,
way of the peaceful warrior's way of the peaceful warrior.
Cool.
That's like a starter for anybody.
Like I mentor our work with like,
who's looking why?
Why is that a start or what?
Uh,
uh,
because it takes you from a basic like,
hey,
here's what's going on too.
Like,
here's like potential here.
Got It.
Ultimate potential.
Like you can't fathom that,
but if you continue to put one foot in front of the other,
you can achieve these things.
You can do what you set your mind out to,
right.
If you're willing to take those steps,
it may not happen tomorrow,
but it can happen.
Um,
and I,
I think that aging is just,
once you get to a certain level,
it's like,
wow.
Like every little piece is like,
whoa.
Layers upon layers upon layers that can make sense at any point and of the day
for me at this point,
you know?
And that's,
I think the beauty in it.
Cool.
Thank you,
Gabby.
Oh my goodness.
I think
I,
you know,
I then,
this sounds ridiculous,
but I read atlas shrugged when I was 15 and I gave that book to a lot of people
because it shifted just sort of how I looked at certain things.
And obviously on the simple read,
I think I've given the alchemist to quite a lot of young people because it's
that reminder
as you go out in the world and you're looking for all these things,
um,
that sometimes it is within us or right.
You know,
again,
we laugh like we're back on quietly.
I grew up on coy,
you know,
it's like you go around the whole world and sometimes what you're looking for is
right in front of you.
Yeah.
And I think it's more true to the idea of even,
um,
something about yourself or marriage or whatever.
It's like,
it's just right there.
You just have to work at it.
With atlas shrugged,
it's very popular in Silicon Valley.
Of course.
It's very,
very popular.
Uh,
I was 15 when I read that book.
That's a big book.
That's it.
That's a big book to tackle person when I was younger.
What did,
uh,
I mean,
is,
um,
is that still a book that you would give to people or is that just for a period
of time?
I think it was,
I was in my,
the world is not as,
it seems a phase in my life,
you know,
probably till I was about 23 or four.
But I think it's just sort of a good reminder about,
it's not about not taking things at face value,
but it's about maybe creating your own truth because we don't,
we can't really figure it out any other truth.
Right.
And the objective truth that applies to everyone.
So I think I certainly would give it now,
but maybe I would give other books now.
Got It.
Blared well,
I'm going to go big here.
At one point I felt there was only one book in,
in,
in my opinion,
in the world,
which was the Bible.
Okay.
And,
uh,
and I,
and I've been through quite a few times.
And you were,
you raised religious?
No.
You were nuts.
All right.
And,
uh,
but that's where I found the truth.
Did I found that,
that,
and I found that and now you didn't gift it as,
as that I gifted the teachings in it.
And I think the parables are such a,
I love parable teaching because it's so tangible.
But when you look at just the basis of what you know,
and,
and I,
and what I find is that when you find the truth,
it doesn't matter what the religion is because the truth is a golden thread that
winds its way through all kinds of stuff.
And so,
uh,
that's just was the first book that I found a lot of truth in it and that,
and then I was able to share that with people,
parables and,
and then you run into so many situations in your life,
and if you just look at basically the 10 commandments and you live that way,
it would increase the quality of your life.
Now,
you know,
as a young kid,
books that had the most influence on me,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
the Lord of the rings was like a huge thing when I was young.
My mom read those books to me and,
and uh,
where like before I could even read.
And so I went through the trilogy of those as a young man and,
you know,
Jonathan Livingston,
seagull and the Dune and all these other fantasy books.
But,
but the Bible really,
I mean,
that thing just had,
you know,
and then now if you came,
if you asked me today like,
what book am I gifting everybody today?
Well,
I'm,
I'm gifting a natural born heroes,
you know,
like,
that's my,
that's my book of the year.
We have a book club in our clan,
book comedy
or in the gym.
We trained together and then made the book of the week or the book of the month.
And we ever,
you know,
whoever gets one,
we go and,
you know,
of course Rick is always a big contributor to the hunches hooked barkers and I'm
just,
everybody's contributing,
you know?
Uh,
and they'll all get it survivals,
another great deep survival,
Lawrence Gonzalez.
That's an incredible book.
Um,
and speaking about just fear and dealing with dealing with fear.
But this natural born heroes is my,
that's my latest kind of crazy just because of,
you know,
again,
but all of these all fic,
I mean,
all,
uh,
you know,
not know fiction and nonfiction,
nonfiction truth.
It's all because I don't it the way my mind works.
I don't want,
I mean if someone,
like I had the fiction when I was young to create imagination and fantasy,
but really what I,
I,
hunger is truth.
Like what is the truth?
What are facts give me information that I can apply.
I want to be able to apply this stuff to life.
So here's,
here's a question about some truths and testing truth that I'm really curious to
ask you.
And that is a,
you're just testing stuff.
You know,
I every once in a while,
every once in a while know that,
you know,
walking around with a drip bag attached to me occasionally.
Uh,
you're known as an innovator in the sort of water sports world,
whether it's towing,
surfing,
a foil board,
uh,
or any number of other things.
Golf,
no exact land now.
Exactly.
So,
but he's,
he's evolved,
it's grown legs,
moved under land.
Uh,
what is enabled to contribute in that way because people have been playing in
the water for a very long time.
Uh,
w w w what is the,
what are the characteristics or the moments that led to you being able to have
these breakthroughs of the,
or contribute to these innovations?
I think a combination of a couple things.
It's,
I think there's a,
for a little bit of a formula that I've been fortunate enough to be subjected to
through how I was raised in,
and then,
uh,
you know,
like again,
being exposed to,
you know,
the Lord of the rings in Dune in some of these really incredible imagination.
So development of imagination.
But you know,
Thomas Edison is quoted as saying,
you know,
all you need to be an inventor is an imagination and a pile of junk.
Right?
And so,
you know,
when I lived at the end of a road that you know,
where you didn't call people to fix stuff,
you fixed it and you know,
you didn't have anything that was,
you couldn't go buy stuff.
You had to make stuff.
And so you,
you know,
and then I grew up in a,
in a way where I was,
you know,
there was racial thing we could.
So I was not like for how I was born.
Right?
So then I would be like,
well why would I be worried about what people think when I do something that
makes him upset?
Right?
They're already upset.
They were upset for how I would want.
So some of those things,
you know,
where you have an imagination and you're not working,
you know you're willing to subject yourself to failure.
Right?
That's a big part of it.
Of any innovation you've got to willing to crash and burn and at the cost of
looking like a fool,
people laughing at you and you just,
and not letting that dictate what you do.
I think peer pressure,
you know,
if,
if it was up to other people,
they wouldn't let you do anything.
No,
we didn't create anything because that we all watch that watch a stupid,
whether it's your dad or,
you know what I mean?
I used to have,
I had a teacher tell me once in school,
you can't eat your surfboard,
you know,
or you're not,
you can't eat.
You're a boy.
You can have your cert though.
Meaning you're not like,
that's not going to pay the bills.
No,
you're not ever going to make a life out of,
out of using that or I'm just saying.
But those are all the,
you know,
when you say
worst advice ever,
or maybe you take that as fuel wrong guy to say that all I'll show you are,
but,
but so I think it's,
I'll,
I think a lot of those are a lot of the factors,
right?
It's those,
those are the key elements.
I think if you look at any,
anybody who's willing to subject themselves to failure and,
and,
and relentless pursuit,
understanding that list that don sits in the wheel house,
it is like it's not going away.
It's not going away and talk about it and write a book,
write it down.
So give me an example of,
of noxious,
I mean the obsessiveness or the persistent because it isn't,
it's weird.
It's not so destructively obsessive,
but it's just this tone that you'd kind of noticed.
You and God,
that's still there.
Huh?
Is um,
standup paddling.
Okay.
So 1998 or seven or so,
Laird decided I'm going to,
you know,
try that.
It's another way to train.
He was on long board using Kayak paddles and then taping handles and then be
free.
You know what we're driving to some house who is asked to Malama is that it was
and on Maui,
like extended what in paddle.
So he did for the canoe paddle is in Hawaii.
So Larry went to him and said,
oh,
can you make it longer?
And then breaking that one and breaking another one.
And then,
you know,
just trying new boards and oh that guy doesn't have boards,
blanks big enough for standup paddleboard.
So I've got to find a guy,
oh there's a guy in San Diego,
just like going nonstop,
nonstop break things go out and just,
and then on top of it do it every day.
Like down winter,
you know,
another down wonder like,
so in Maui when it's went to windy,
if this,
you know,
to serve,
maybe that means a winds probably up and in Mali it's very windy.
So he you,
he gets dropped off at one point and then goes with the wind down and stand up
paddling.
And that was really one of the best first things that he used it for.
And then,
you know,
you incorporated surfing later.
But I mean just persistent and constant everyday.
Even foiling,
I really,
if I look at foiling,
it's like layered ultimately has been practicing rigorously for the last seven
years,
quietly,
patiently to get a ride and maybe another ride coming.
But a ride that he had this winter on a wave that he's been secretly thinking
about probably for 40 years of his life.
So there's a patients but a relentlessness that I'm like,
wow,
that is Kudos to you,
that you can hang in there and do it.
So
are you that simple that you just can't,
I mean it's pretty impressive though.
I mean youth of course they'll have exhibited.
No,
no,
it's very different.
I would never different because you've achieved a lot in many different areas.
So how was it different?
It says like,
I'm s,
you know,
Sterno I'm a low steady flame layer goes at it at a different degree.
He gets there much quicker for very long period of time.
Yeah.
And it,
and also just physically that he can express himself for that kind of endurance
is different.
A lot of mine is mental.
It's a different,
it's just different.
Um,
but I really respect that.
And Laird,
because also he does it when no one's watching.
He doesn't tell any,
he does not talking about it unless it's to have a conversation about how to
approach it,
attack and improve it.
And so it is a very personal,
um,
quest that he's on for his reasons of his own.
Um,
like one day we were driving up a PCH and there was like literally all these
standup paddle is out there and I can remember clearly when it was layered,
dragging his one friend lock out there for seven or eight years before anyone
was stand up paddling.
And I said,
how does that make you feel?
And he goes,
I knew I was having so much fun.
So it was never the idea of like,
oh,
I'm going to somehow bring this into modern day.
It was,
I'm doing this for myself because I have an idea that I want to express.
And so it's one of the things I appreciate or will it bring me fun and joy and
enjoyment straight up.
So part of the reason you guys are happy,
it's that Semyon high on the list are you're laughing Laird.
So what's what's happening over there?
Could you explain to people also because the,
the foil boarding,
now this is,
takes my like,
fear factor,
do a whole new level because you're basically,
well why don't you explain it for folks,
but it's not like you just jumped off the board if things are going sideways.
Right?
I mean you're,
you're a cat.
So what was Samurai Sword?
What does it,
what does it foil board,
which a,
it's a,
a surfboard or just a board,
like a wakeboard with a big strike,
like a foil,
which is,
you know,
you see the America's Cup guys are using them and it's a big,
it's a big shaggy feet,
three feet long by 48 inches beneath the board.
But eat the board.
It's like a big fin.
It's a hybrid.
It's a big thing that makes the board fly off the water,
but you're attached to,
it was snowboard boots and bindings.
Um,
which,
you know,
you don't swim well with boots and,
uh,
but it's,
it's something that we've kind of came upon as,
as you know,
all of it's about an evolution to try to ride the biggest surf in the world.
And so we first we started and,
uh,
you know,
with prone guns conventionally and then what I'm prone gun,
like when you lay down on these big guns and then we knew that the,
the size of the border,
when is a gun?
It's designed for giant waves too long.
It's what,
it's what all the,
you know,
the modern manual way to catch waves.
Got It.
And it's an ancient way of doing it,
but it's the,
you know,
we found a cap and we should,
and we realized there was a ceiling and then that,
and then we,
and that's because of the bigger waves move faster or bigger waves move faster.
We're not able to physically keep up,
keep up.
And,
and that's where the con,
the concept of towing came from.
The idea of being towed onto one and using the power to match the speed of the
wave in order to ride bigger surf.
And when we did that,
it made us,
allowed us to ride smaller equipment that was actually faster and then we could
perform on these giant ways.
And when you say giant,
just for people who may not be familiar with big wave surfing,
what is what,
what are we talking?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
you start giant,
giant starts at,
you know,
at,
at 50 foot faces and then we go,
then it goes above,
so 60 70 80 foot faces.
I mean,
that's giant,
big surface.
You know,
when we say it's big,
it's 50 and below.
And then when he goes to giant and then it,
and then it goes to like read ridiculous,
enormous,
you know,
whatever.
There's giant,
there's big,
there's giant,
there's enormous,
you know,
and then everybody can get into,
it's 82.5 feet and all that stuff.
But,
but we,
we found a cap,
you know,
at manual.
Then we found a cap.
Ultimately we found a cap with Tony.
Tony,
what's the,
where's the cap at about?
Probably about,
uh,
and,
and the range of 100 feet.
So that's,
that's,
and we know there's a cap there.
We know that there's an ability,
he knows because he's been there.
So we know there's a cap.
And so at that point in the continual pursuit,
it was how do we get,
we're,
what are we going to need to do?
And we know that the only way we can do that is to not be on the surface.
Because surface tension is the thing that creates the most drag,
which is what is stopping us when once the waves are moving at a certain speed.
How did you do the,
what was the moment or the conversation or the event where it's like,
Holy Shit,
like we could do this.
Like,
because the idea of putting the strut and the,
you know,
having that foil like fact on a board,
it hadn't occurred previously.
So what,
well no,
it actually,
there was,
it was,
you know,
it's none of the steps.
I always say every,
there's no new idea,
just a new application of an old idea.
So this,
uh,
there is,
a seated,
a seated foil called an air chair in the garage on Maui.
And one summer we were playing around in,
some of my friend goes,
oh,
this guy's got this weird contraption.
So we went over the house,
it was in the corner,
had dust on it,
cobwebs,
and be like,
Hey,
what's that?
Oh,
some stupid thing called an air chair.
I mean,
it wasn't bad enough that he would let us keep it,
but we got it and we wrote it and we were,
and what were you being towed behind something and you're strapped to it by
Murphy created it.
Yeah.
And you're strapped to it with a seat.
And I thought it was for handicapped initially because the position was very,
your strap
and that's a big institute.
People behind boats with them.
Yeah.
And now they have a new one.
Now they have,
while the sky ski where they do flips and people ride these things and do
amazing things on them.
And you towed behind a boat,
like a Waterski boat.
And uh,
and so we got one.
And the first thing that we,
we wanted to do was stand on it because we go,
listen,
seeding is again,
part of our mottoes,
you know,
stand up,
stand up on the golf boards,
standup on standup paddling,
stand up,
like standing up is better position to be.
And we're humans,
you know,
city,
it's not great.
Crawling is not wonderful.
Laying down is even worse.
So we,
uh,
you know,
so we started to stand on it and as soon as we stood on and we go,
oh,
we can stand on.
I mean,
it wasn't,
it was hard because we were,
you know,
using the seat and kind of,
and we didn't have bindings.
And so,
uh,
I asked him is extremely precarious,
very bad,
and it's got,
and it has a big sharp blade on the bottom of it.
So it's not something you don't want to be attached to it,
because if the thing comes around,
it's,
you know,
it could be a bad,
the reaper,
there's a problem.
And,
uh,
but so then we just took,
we took that and uh,
and we asked the guy if it was okay if we,
if we,
uh,
played with it as long as we didn't damage any of it.
And he said sure.
So I took the foil out of the board and I took a wakeboard and we made kind of a
make shift,
uh,
housing so that the foil could fit on there.
And I,
and I,
and I put snowboard boots on it cause we had been doing a lot of snowboarding
and we booted ourselves to it and w and within the first air to all of a sudden
we're standing on this thing of flying.
And as soon as we student flew and we knew we could control it,
we were like,
oh no,
we have to go on.
The waves were like,
this is going to be,
this is going to be for waiver.
But did you talk,
you tow behind a ski or a boat for like almost three years,
maybe more.
And flatwater they'll learn lots of practice.
Not to mention where are you messing around with the hippity hop?
Wasn't that the hippity hop or is that for tow surfing?
No,
the hippity hop was for that was flotation device.
What is the idea?
There used to go out in front of our house in Maui and let the hippity hop and
he would try to do it with spare air.
I'm so lost.
What does the hippity hop knows?
I have no idea what anybody
knows the light but no,
that's a giant ball when you're [inaudible] it's a,
it's a physio ball with a kettlebell horns and like the face of a horse on it or
so 30 is to take those,
fold them up really small and attach you to spare air,
which is like basically one shot of air if you're for diver or somebody under.
Yeah,
and in case he was trying to figure out ways to have water proof location and
we're in the giant surf.
We were still kind of searching for flotation because we were worried about
brief flotation.
You mean like the pre,
pre a LifeVest I guess.
Yeah.
But this was pre us using life vests in giant surf.
Now it's now it's everybody.
Flotation devices in the giants here.
Let's just say there's a lot of stages between like now layered is riding with
Terry and they're doing it in Kohai two,
three or four years behind boats and you know,
skis,
one broken one broken ties.
Because we were in the beginning of the,
of the conception of guiding as well.
Yeah.
So we we kind of warning yeah,
that we start,
I mean more or less the modern toe board is what made kiteboarding possible
initially.
And then the wake came in after,
but we were the first ones that get the French,
the notch restartable the non-recyclable here,
let's talk about it where you just release the guy and he'd just fly as far as
he could until he cracked it.
Then it was over over and sometimes you'd be like two miles out to sea with a
giant quilt you've ever tried to swim with a quilt.
It's very hard like a giant quilt.
The quilt and the lunch tray.
So literally the board wants like a lunch tray and a quilt and it's like you're
two miles out and you're looking at the shore and you're like,
this is not a good day.
I mean he was good until you crashed.
And then
how does the hip with the rabbit phase fit into all this?
Because it's all,
I'm just saying it was all part of like simultaneously trying to figure out the
equipment and how to ride it and use it,
how to be safer and make it possible.
Would she be like on the foil board with the Hippie town?
It's where this lady's are smart for that.
He'd be with it folded up and then he'd go out where there was some,
we know Whitewater messing around and then he didn't implode,
dropped off and then pull it and then it would pop up and now it started just
seeing if it was okay.
So We'd have a pre inflated you to the off type dog waste.
So then we weed,
we get dropped off in front of a giant wave and then,
but we realized that the hippity hop and just bang you in the head and so,
and you come up and you'd be face down in the hippie hop would be out of the
water but you would still be under.
So we stopped the hippity hop.
This goes back to like what she was
talking about with his,
and you know the whole incessant like I'm just going to do this.
But here's the thing is I actually know guys who have taken,
who have attempted to do the foil boarding and they just gave up because they're
like,
it's too hard.
It's too difficult.
They did not have the patience or the time to want to invest themselves into
something which is like,
which is also why a lot of this stuff just works.
Like with the relationships that they have and even the relationship I have with
them.
Is it,
it is a,
it's a commitment.
It's a full commitment.
Now why do you think,
why do you think w Laird has the sticktuitiveness when these other people don't?
Do you think it's a,
and I'm not,
I won't make it totally multiple choice questions.
These are the options kind of running through my head,
right?
Just having observed how you guys live.
Like is it something innate possible,
right?
Is it influences that he's had?
Is it the peer group that he surrounds himself with or some other factor?
We're all see all of the above because like I grew up in a very similar fashion,
um,
where I was very rebellious where I was told I wasn't going to be able to do
things.
I didn't,
I,
I screwed around.
I did.
And now it's like you come around full circle to that where you learn how to get
good at what something you were good at.
And where he learned early on is what it seems is that,
wow,
this worked,
this happened.
I'm making a living off of surfing or whatever.
That was that like,
and he's not doing it in a contest.
He's doing it on his own.
Like,
Eh,
she's grown up in an environment where it wasn't the greatest family environment
to where she's thriving and they've,
they've created this whole thing where,
you know,
I was able to do things that I shouldn't.
Like I was told I wasn't going to do and I did and it was because of the,
I was so passionate about what I was doing and I was willing to commit to that
and continue to see the results of what that brought,
that that became,
oh,
this is what makes sense.
You know what I mean?
I just wrote something on an Instagram post yesterday kind of about this where
it's like if you don't have the ability to pay attention enough to your training
that to understand what rest is,
you're now in an OCD like behavior to where it's like you don't even understand
how you're going to get better at something where it's just paying attention and
it's like,
hey,
if I'm assuming if you see it as hey,
you said a key thing,
they're paying attention but but also paying attention but also part of paying
attention is being aware of what's happening and seeing it before it's done.
And so I mean at the end it's about envisioning it too.
Right?
You can see what you have to be able to see it to continue to pursue it.
Okay.
This is a really is a super important point.
So for yourself,
what would be an example of that?
Of seeing it and being able to,
well,
just any,
any one of the things I've been involved with.
So knowing,
knowing like for example,
we were able to foil some giant surf this this season.
Now we,
up until then,
we haven't really ever been,
I was in doubt of being able to,
even though [inaudible] in instinctually knew that this,
this is definitely the way to do this,
this is the DA,
but I didn't,
I haven't seen it,
you know,
and,
and again,
uh,
it's,
it's that,
it's that ability to,
to see,
see it before it's
to note to know it,
and then you have all those other things that you need to pursue,
but you got to,
you have to actually be able to see it welling up.
Oswaldo view motivated.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
so Brian,
I have a question for you because you've,
you've worked with so many athletes and uh,
you know,
I might want to ask you guys the same question and that is,
uh,
and,
you know,
Kelly is an expert at this as well,
but,
uh,
what would your advice be to a,
say a,
it doesn't really matter.
The age,
30,
35,
40 doesn't matter.
But as a former athlete who's beating themselves up,
may or may not be me.
Uh,
no,
it's not me,
but somebody who's really just beaten the shit out of themselves,
who wants to either continue training or get back to the point where they're
competing and God knows what.
Right.
You've,
you've observed so many athletes,
um,
what should they do more of?
What should they do?
Less of?
More humility.
Yeah.
What's everything?
That's why I thought it was so important that you come up here.
Yeah.
Was,
it wasn't,
oh,
tiny.
Did I need a dose,
Tim?
With humility?
It's no,
it's like,
hey,
come see what it's like to apply something that you can do for the rest of your
life.
Yup.
If you can't see what you're doing,
if you think at 20 that I can just bang away and go as heavy as I want,
as hard as I want,
as long as I want.
And it's not going to have repercussions.
You're not looking at it correctly.
And I've been there,
I've done it.
I,
and I,
and,
and I think this,
this goes to like,
this also comes around to,
I've learned a lot in the fact that I know,
like for one,
I don't have the only program.
I don't like what I'm putting out isn't the only way.
There are a thousand ways it's,
Eh,
I,
it's no longer about me being right.
It's no,
and that,
that's a lot with what they're doing.
It's not about being right.
It's,
I see the potential of this and yeah,
the world now knows standup paddle.
Like they now know it and it's not about I'm right.
This was me.
Like it's not that it's not,
you know,
I think it's,
we're,
as an athlete,
if you've beaten yourself up to the point to where it's like,
oh,
I've got to deal with this injury,
I've got to deal with this stuff.
I'm not what I used to be.
It's,
well,
you have a lifetime right now.
What do you want to do?
Yeah.
Is it about winning?
Is it about being the best at something or is it about how,
how much better can I be tomorrow at what I'm doing today and can I just chip
away at a little of that?
And that is what they have,
not only I have learned
to surround myself with is people who are doing that,
but that's what these two are doing.
That's what Kelly's doing.
That's what you've done with your career is you've literally immersed yourself
into an environment where you have bread.
I'm going to meet people who want to be in the long game and that's what it's
about.
And,
and it really ultimately comes down at,
and that is for life,
we call that train out is right kind of training,
getting training for life that yeah,
that's what the truth is.
There's nothing further from that is this is what the truth is.
Can't be friends,
professional athlete.
And you know,
I mean I've a bunch of friends that are professionals,
but one particular one,
and we were talking about his training and everything and I said,
I go,
let me just say what my perspective is.
When I,
when you asked me about training
train in a way so that when you're done playing you can go do all the things you
want to do.
And I don't mean sit around and drink whiskey and smoke cigars.
I mean the things you want to do physically,
like all of the things you want to do.
So have a,
have a training routine and go about your playing so that when you're done doing
that
you can walk.
Maybe that'd be great.
How about you can run,
how about you can sweat how bay you can bike,
how about you can go water,
Ski,
Snow,
who are,
whatever things you want to do because there's obviously some things you're
still going to want to do.
Right.
And,
and,
and so I think that's the,
the focus is right.
Like it's like training for life,
like training in a way that sustainable that you can handle.
Like you said,
you can't just take the hammering for the next 60 years and then wonder,
well man,
I can't even walk.
And even when you do it that way,
it's still,
you have to do all the pieces to,
you got to remember that,
you know,
as an athlete,
if you got to have,
it's the whole picture.
It's not just the physical,
it's the eating,
it's the sleeping,
it's the relationships,
it's all of those things.
What you're putting in your brain,
what you're putting in your mouth.
I mean these are all who you're hanging out with.
All of that stuff is going to feed into the performance.
Right.
So I noticed for instance,
one thing I had never seen before,
I've seen people roll out on foam rollers.
I've seen people roll out on weird looking,
uh,
devices that,
you know,
Kelly makes it look like sexual,
toys.
Uh,
I've never seen someone roll out on a weight plate before.
Well actually that Kelly Kelly brought that into it had the 45 pounds and I was
like,
that's funny cause I was just,
somebody else had just given me the kettle bell.
So the kettle bell was a wicked one until I got the plateau of Ucla.
Did you say gave you the,
the handle of the kettle bell.
Yeah.
You handled it in the gut and then,
and then,
and then he won a Kelly one up me with the 45 pound platter,
but I didn't have that one by the pool.
So I use a 10 pound planner.
But just to get in just the plate.
Yeah.
He didn't play plan.
Another important thing and that Brian was saying is that hopefully you hope all
of us and you do this all the time.
Yeah.
You're the ultimate
student because you have to adjust.
You always have to adjust and be open like this was working,
but I,
maybe I should change it or you know,
cause it's,
it's a moving target and be open to other people's,
um,
information and,
and,
and not be threatened by it and,
and give it a try if you're not good at it or whatever.
I think that that's a really important thing because then,
um,
you can keep growing and evolving.
So for those athletes,
I think it's just be open and be a student,
but then you have to be disciplined when you also have to be willing to accept
your,
your weaknesses and cultivate those.
You know,
it's like,
it's funny because everybody,
the strong people all go lift weights.
People all go do yoga and you're like,
wait,
all you flexible people should go bank some iron and all you big weightlifter
should go do some yoga and all,
you know it's like,
but we always gravitate towards our strengths because we want to be in our
glory.
So we're like,
I avoid stretching like,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm now just sore enough and heard enough that I'm like,
okay,
it's time I get,
I get a phone call.
Being the student,
being the student,
being the teacher,
all that.
And,
and also,
and again,
the willingness to fail being one of the key elements to all of those things is
ever present because that means you're willing to subject yourself to,
okay,
I'm,
somebody knows something.
I don't know.
That's failure.
Some new thing you haven't done before that you're not going to be good at.
Like people want to come in and be good at stuff.
That's why the foil board drives half the guys away because they can't just get
on it and rip it the first time.
Just the full board.
But like Brian,
you're saying that,
uh,
I mean obviously a lot of very good athletes come in and do the,
the pool workout and it's like that's a big humility sandwich right there.
Yeah.
I mean,
and not good at it.
Well that's also what needs out people.
Yeah.
Taylor,
we brought a girl,
uh,
a rower up here.
Um,
like crew rower.
She rode with my wife and in 2005 Olympics at all.
Yeah.
And we brought her up here and we put her in the pool and everybody was just
like,
it was astounding.
Like I said,
the elements though,
cause she was already a phenomenal swimmer superstrong long,
hard,
again,
having those key and she was very humble,
but it was odd because she has all the physical attributes,
but she was very humble.
She wanted to learn.
But that's the combination like disposition,
disposition cause you put might and aggression over there.
The water goes,
oh mighty aggressive.
Perfect.
I'll just drown you.
So normally as males we just implement aggression and bustling and that he's not
going to muscle the,
sorry.
So you,
you mentioned weaknesses and strengths and I wanted to touch on something that
you mentioned to me earlier today,
which I found very interesting when we were doing the ammo box ammo box exercise
and a,
you talked about isolating limbs and isolating weaknesses.
Can you elaborate on that a little bit?
We'll,
because we'll just,
I mean,
you know,
and,
and listen,
we know that if you work on being
more ambidextrous that you get better.
It's like,
you know,
you throw knives with your right hand and you're really good at it,
we'll start throwing them with your left hand.
It actually makes you better with your right.
But again,
about isolation of the weaknesses is,
is about being realistic about what your flaws are and,
and,
and working on those.
And that's why anything to do with instability,
when you talk about balance or in the pool,
it really is going to exaggerate those places that normally you can compensate.
There's,
it's hard to compensate in the pool when you have to swim with your left hand if
you have a big dumbbell in your right hand because there's no other lefthand,
there's only the one you have.
And if it doesn't work,
you got to figure out how to make it work.
Right.
And you can really,
and it really shows you,
you can really see,
you know,
you throw a ball with your left hand if you're right handed and you feel like,
oh my gosh,
who's arm is this?
I can't even use this arm or Kik or kick with your left leg.
Or,
or even when you go into stretching and you look at stretching.
Why is my right hamstring so much looser than my left hamstring?
Why is my quad my left quad so much tighter than my right?
Quite all those things.
Those are all weaknesses at the end.
And,
uh,
what do you feel like your current weaknesses are that you're working on?
Oh,
it's ongoing.
I got a lot of destruction,
you know,
I've been beating myself up for a long time,
so my weakness has had more to do with,
with damage,
but,
um,
like I got some hit some hip flexor,
something going on with my right leg because of the load that I put on it.
It why your right leg?
Well,
it's my back leg in service,
but it's also because my left leg has been broken seven times.
So,
um,
that's an surfing or other things,
uh,
other surfing in and other things.
But I broke my ankle a bunch of times.
An arch and a bunch of men.
All the metatarsal,
his and stuff on the left,
the left ankle and the left foot has taken a lot of the,
of the impact.
And so my rights been calm,
caring.
It,
uh,
you know,
for all these extra year.
So it's got,
you know,
my,
my right leg has a couple of,
maybe five or 10 more years of use than my left leg.
So I'm dealing with that,
with that.
Uh,
and,
and the fact is that we're all asymmetrical.
Definitely.
We're all,
I mean,
even,
I told the girls the other day,
I go look at the tennis players.
I go look at their throwing hand and they're like,
they're like,
oh my goodness,
the guy's one arm is so much bigger than the other one.
But you don't even see it unless you look for it.
Focus on it.
Exactly.
So,
I mean,
but you know,
I think that that's,
uh,
you know,
again,
those are the,
you know,
right now,
like I said,
it's a hip thing.
It's a,
you know,
it's,
I mean,
there's always,
and it's elusive thing.
It's moving in,
but even with that,
your brain disciplines,
like I have to say,
Laird is a good patient.
Like if he has homework,
he does his homework.
If he's told to do stretches,
he does a stretches.
Uh,
so you're always,
but that's come out of necessity.
That's because I've been hurt so many times.
I mean,
you really don't learn anything about yourself ultimately until you've been
injured.
Again,
back to the failure back to failure,
whether it's something failed or you did something that made you crash and get
hurt.
But you also,
the thing is that like even Brian mentioned earlier,
there's something that you have that you've discovered is he has the faith that,
oh,
lay both go,
well if I do this then I'll probably be a little better tomorrow.
So they have that faith and that to layered knows,
okay,
if I'm not feeling well,
if I'm,
if I keep trying different things and I stay open and I do my homework,
I can probably be proactive and helping myself get better.
And I think those elements are important because sometimes what happens is,
is sometimes if people aren't feeling well,
they're this age athlete or whatever,
they're so far under it,
they don't have that faith anymore.
Or they don't understand how to unravel that.
Not,
um,
and so I think,
you know,
it's like priming the pump.
Sometimes the water doesn't come out right away.
But then if you just keep going and it'll start to flow.
And I think,
you know,
certainly in this situation,
these guys have seen it enough times.
And I think that that's a really important thing for people.
Well,
the [inaudible] actually have been through it and had success.
Then you give you hope.
Definitely you don't want,
he says your one time when you've been perfectly ironman forever and all of a
sudden something happens and you're like the whole,
the whole house breaks in shock and you can't wear,
if you've been through it and you've recovered once and then you did it and had
another thing and you've had enough stuff,
but you made it back through it.
You know,
you,
it builds the belief that you can do it.
I think another piece of,
of this,
and I'd look to,
to ask you about this,
Brian,
uh,
is that a lot of athletes surround themselves with people who love to
commiserate.
So an athlete will be like,
Oh,
well,
you know,
I just turned 30 and you know,
once you turned 30,
like,
oh my God,
my aching joints.
Now I know you guys are both covering your faces.
And the reason is,
you know,
I've,
uh,
but this is so common and then everyone sits around and bitches and moans and
they use that as an excuse in society too.
But what I love about,
you know,
hanging out with you guys are like Titus,
right?
I guess it was like there's a huge,
there's a photograph.
So Titus was in the surfing episode of the Tim Ferriss Experiment,
the TV show and walked into his garage and there's this photo of him surfing a
50 plus foot way of,
and I'm like,
what is that?
And he goes,
Oh yeah,
it was my 50th birthday.
And I was just like,
I have no excuses.
Like shame on me forever.
Even thinking I have an excuse.
And uh,
hanging out with Rick for instance.
And then I guess,
um,
the name is Don Wildman.
Is that,
um,
uh,
dawn picture of him back then?
Could you explain for two people?
Uh,
and,
and then Brian,
I'd love to ask you outside of the examples I just gave,
sort of,
who inspires you in that same way?
Like my,
one of my,
my only coach really I'm working with right now is a 60,
just turned 62,
a former four time world record holder and Olympic weightlifting.
And he can still do what he used to do.
I mean,
not necessarily the same way,
but cold.
You can just go out and jump into like asked to,
he'll snatch and tennis shoes.
Uh,
and it's so inspiring to me because whenever I'm like,
Oh,
woe is me,
like,
moo a poor lift ankle.
I'm like,
suck it up.
Fair.
It's like,
give me a break.
So Wildman,
um,
can you explain Don Wildman 82,
uh,
you know,
80 days is heli,
uh,
80 days of snowboarding last year.
I just went heli snowboarding with him like a month ago or two months ago in
Alaska.
Uh,
just,
you know,
I mean,
hell,
he boarding is a rigorous activity a week straight,
you know,
15,
16 runs a day,
you know,
third,
fourth day you're,
you're wobbly,
not a word out of the,
out of the gunslinger.
And,
uh,
you know,
he just is like,
but,
but when you meet him,
you know,
you,
you his,
his,
his hunger for information,
his youthful enthusiasm,
you know,
it's like,
I think that is such a key element when you look at any of these guys,
you see an enthusiasm in him.
And I think that's what happens to a lot of athletes.
I think they just lose their enthusiasm,
their burnout.
They've been doing their sports since they were five or 10 and they'd been in
the pressure around it.
And so I believe ultimately that it's a conscious decision that with a physical
manifestation.
And so dawn was never accepting it as being,
you know,
he,
Oh,
you know,
the guy that holds the,
he always gives you stuff like the guy that held the Olympic record for lifting
was 52 or 54 before steroids and blah,
blah,
and all this stuff.
You know,
when you see that and,
and,
but what's great about somebody like dawn,
who's my,
my guy that I look to,
is that just,
there it is.
Yeah.
You don't have to imagine what it looks like there it is.
It's alive.
It's,
well,
I mean [inaudible] I put don on a bicycle and I can take pretty much almost
anybody on a bicycle unless you are like a professional bicycle list and he will
hammer you,
you will be hammered and you will be asking me how old is the guy up in the
front with the gray hair?
Like 82 he's going to hand and he can still do what?
Like 1517 pull up some in.
Oh yeah,
he's a poet machine.
Amongst other things amongst that system,
that's just a small,
that's a small tip of the iceberg.
What would you attribute that to?
Like why has he not lost his enthusiasm and maybe a different way of putting it?
As for people who are like,
God,
I would love to have that enthusiasm but I just don't,
like how do I develop that?
What do I do?
Like I,
I,
I'm willing to work.
Like what do I do to have that youthful?
Well,
I mean,
I think in his,
his case he's got a couple driving forces.
I mean,
he,
he has guilt and,
and he loves to eat.
So that's one at,
like dawn has a unique thing about that that he can implement.
Like he wants to eat whatever he wants and he,
me and he loves to eat like,
you know,
cakes and pies and ice cream and like,
he'll just devour that stuff,
but he,
at the same time,
he wants to be,
he does it.
He's not going to be fat.
He doesn't want any fat on his body and,
and so,
so for him he's earning it like he's for it.
In this particular case,
he's earning it right.
And also to the,
Oh,
he always says it takes the piss and vinegar Outta here.
You know what I mean?
Like he knows how it affects his mood and how it makes them feel.
And so it,
once you subject yourself to it for long enough and you're consistent enough,
you know,
it's,
you start to get addicted to that.
You're light food tastes great.
My sleeping's rate,
my sex is unbelievable.
I'm just,
you know,
it's like all this stuff where he just,
and then you don't want to lose that,
then then you use,
it becomes the new normal,
right.
That's the norm.
And then you don't,
and then that becomes the driving force and then it's easier and you,
and it's never an option.
Yeah.
You never make it.
It's like Gabby says,
you know,
it's not like if you don't choose whether you want to brush your teeth or not,
you don't go,
I'm not going to brush my teeth this week.
You know,
I don't need to do that.
It's just something you do.
It's like,
well,
exactly.
But no,
but yeah.
Well the other thing don does,
that's very genius.
It's goes back to a Brian side,
which is,
he solicits people to be in his group because no man can really do it alone.
So he always has these guys around him,
most of them quite a bit younger.
So the energy goes into the pot and
roles or girls.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
yeah,
one girl.
Yeah,
but I'm just saying,
but he's got,
but he's got to grow,
but he loves to be a host and bring people with him and do things.
You,
the bike camp at your music set up for you and you do everything for you.
Well it seems like you're doing,
he does that,
that they do that star that does that,
that I,
the host and I do that.
Like,
it's like we invite like I'm picking up a girl this afternoon at lax who's going
to be staying with us for a week to train and participate in,
you know,
it's like this is thank you for your 80 units of energy contribution to the pot
just gone up.
Now we're going to absorb that.
And also to it also,
it also confirms what you're,
that you're,
it's like a reminder.
Yeah.
You know,
because again,
it's like,
like Gabby said with the stand up paddlers that at the end when you go through
what you went through today and then you and I see your face and I know what it
did to you and I know later you'll be like sitting somewhere and you'll want to
go to sleep.
I'll be like,
hey just give me the call.
Like call me cause I want,
cause it's confirmation of that you're not alone because when you're alone in
something,
a lonely place is up as a,
as an unmotivated place.
Oh that's a great way.
It's an unmotivated.
When you're lonely,
it's very unique to find a complete loner that's as full maximum motivation,
really motive.
We are communal,
we are communal.
But that's why we're subjected to all of this peer pressure too.
We're subjected to social pressure of,
hey now your 30 year over hill,
what are you going to do now?
So you don't even,
but that's social stuff that we implement.
So,
but we,
the reverses that is,
hey,
we're all together and you're 60 or 70.
I'm 50,
I'm 30.
We're all going,
let's go.
Yeah.
So definitely I was talking to,
um,
my,
uh,
my trainer's wife who's awesome and she also has a couple of world's records,
and super sweet sweetheart and she's,
I guess 55 around there.
And she was saying,
she said to me,
she's like,
you know,
when people start to get old,
she's,
and she said,
it's when they stop jumping when this stop jumping and uh,
you know,
we can fuck talking about whether that's right or wrong,
but the,
the followup was even more interesting to me because she has a daughter,
a young daughter,
and there was something stuck in the tree
and she got up into the tree and her daughter was like,
mom,
be careful.
It's really high.
And she climbed up 20,
25 feet,
got the thing out,
climb back down.
She was like,
do you know what it says to a daughter to see her mom who's 55 effortlessly go
up into a tree,
get it and come down.
Like,
it just shows her possibilities that,
or it'll make her,
it's like,
you know,
sometimes they take your kid,
see you train like you,
like we trained.
They may be like,
hmm,
maybe I don't want to train you.
Me.
I don't want to climb tree.
Mom's crazy though.
Brian,
who other,
I speak,
speaking of crazy,
speaking of crazy evil,
uh,
Brian,
who else sort of inspires you?
People you look up to,
uh,
as,
say that,
uh,
Don Wildman type.
It doesn't have to be someone older than you,
but like,
who are the people you look to as inspiration when maybe you're feeling
overwhelmed or burned out or,
or fill in the blank?
Um,
I do a decent amount of reading.
and a decent amount of watching of documentaries and a decent amount of being a
voyeur is stick with people who are creative regardless of that creativity.
Um,
a lot of it has to do with food sometimes because,
yeah.
Well,
it's just,
you,
you look at what they're doing like 20 years ago,
maybe a little longer,
a chef's were not looked at as anything,
right.
They were just here,
you're in the back cooking right now.
If you've paid enough attention.
They are these masterful creators of things.
You know,
one of the great,
one of the best documentaries I've ever seen is called,
it has a movie called spinning plates,
Spinning plates,
spinning plates.
It's a must see if you're really looking to progress yourself because there's a,
there's a guy by the name of,
uh,
his name's grant,
any,
and he runs one of the top seven restaurants in the world and he has this way of
dealing with food much like you see a lot of great chefs at this point,
whether to Nomo Tracia he,
he's a United States citizen named grant Achatz.
Yes.
Grant Achatz and Alinea.
Alinea yeah.
So he's got to linea,
but,
so they're following a linea,
but they're also following a homestead in like Iowa.
That's just this family run place that the entire community goes to.
And then they're following this Mexican place in Tucson,
which is barely making it,
and they play the entire show.
And you're watching this movie,
this documentary on all of these places.
And as they're progressing in their trials or tribulations and all this stuff,
and at the end they grant has seen the entire thing and you think he's this like
Demi God of,
of food.
And he explains what he does.
And he goes,
and you know,
and what I'm doing is,
is if somebody can come into my restaurant and they feel that they taste the
food and they feel it,
and I get in and they come to ask in the back,
they can talk to the chef and they say,
hey,
I feel like I know you.
And he goes,
that's exactly what I'm going.
That's exactly what I want to do.
And,
and,
and in essence,
that's what I do is it's like,
I want people to see how I see the world.
Don't take everything I do,
but,
but it inspire you to some degree.
But he literally goes at the end of this thing,
the Mexican restaurant is doing the exact same thing and it failed it at that
point in the movie.
It literally,
they had had,
they went bankrupt and they didn't make it,
and you know,
it didn't last.
And he's like,
but nobody understood that.
No,
because they think because it's not flashy and it's this thing that they're not
getting that experience yet.
It was that experience,
not homestead.
That's the exact same thing I'm doing.
They're just expressing themselves in another way through this and we're not
taking the time to understand that.
And I think that's where one of the missing links is with a lot of people is we
want this great,
huge,
massive inspiration.
But the fact is,
is every bit of an inspiration you need or want is in front of you in anything
you want.
If you're willing to go the length to be obsessive enough about it.
Yeah.
And,
and I think that it like,
it's not just food with me,
it's like I just watched some coach do something the other day who,
I remember this kid like seven years ago at my buddy's gym and he was just this
little kid who was just learning and wanting to understand.
He's doing things right now from a gymnastics perspective that he's showing
people through social media of him doing things and how he sees the world that
is just amazing.
And I'm like,
fuck,
I get so much out of that and I'm like,
I'm going to go and do some stuff that's like inspiring me to do that.
And it's whether it's what you choose to get out of things.
I think,
what's his name?
His name's Colen parody.
Colon parody.
Yeah.
Cool.
Check it out.
No,
I think it's,
it's so true.
I mean the,
like you were saying,
um,
layered that there are no new ideas,
just sort of old concepts that he has applied to new areas.
It's like you don't have to look in fitness to find inspiration to be better in
fitness.
You can,
you can look at someone like grant Kratz amazing.
Of course.
Yeah.
I mean he cooked for,
I think it was period of one or two years with no taste because he had yet a
cancer tongue cancer,
like a,
who was it?
Beethoven,
I think,
who composed without being able to hear just insane.
So I,
I want to be very,
uh,
this is,
this is so much fun,
but I want to be respectful of your time.
So I'll just ask one or two more questions.
Um,
so why don't we start with 'em and I'll ask the same,
same question of all three of you,
but,
uh,
Gabby,
ladies first.
Uh,
what advice would you give to your 30 year old self?
Oh,
well,
I always say I would have,
and I mentioned this earlier,
but certainly not to take anything personal,
but also maybe don't hold yourself back.
I think sometimes,
and I think this is a trade of a female more than of a male.
Um,
we have a tendency sometimes to sit on our talents and potentials because we
don't want to offend anyone or we don't want to be singled out.
You know,
I heard a great story.
I had a coach once that said he was an assistant coach to the men's,
a USA volleyball team.
And in this game it was one point.
And the coach said,
look straight at Karcher cry,
said I need you to put this ball away and you'd win this game.
And it was like boom,
okay.
And he said it was amazing.
And then he did it and then he had his opportunity.
He was coaching a bunch of women at a very high level and he did the same thing
to the athlete.
That was the one.
And everyone,
it didn't work because all the other,
it was like a singling out that women we have a hard time with instead of
honoring understanding that you can be singled out,
but still for the greater good.
Right.
So I think I,
if I would have maybe,
um,
not tried to,
I think I sat on some of my talents a little bit.
And um,
and also I think I,
I certainly,
like I said,
tried to,
I took things personally,
so I would tell that person,
like,
don't take it personal.
You know,
I tell my kids,
learn how to say,
I'm sorry,
that doesn't work for me.
It's,
it's,
again,
I've learned a lot from being around men.
I respect a lot of traits.
You can,
you can deliver a message without emotion.
Usually women in order to finally stand up for themselves,
they have to be kind of ramped up and then it just comes out ballistic instead
of like,
no,
that doesn't work for me.
And then we don't.
And also not to then second guessed that you've laid that line down.
Um,
I think that that's really important and I think,
um,
you know,
it's important to like if you have gifts and talents,
whatever they are,
don't feel guilty and bad or weird about it and,
and,
but you know,
you don't have to be a schmuck.
I mean,
you don't have to,
you know,
I always tell kids,
if you're on the team,
you're lucky and if you're the best one,
you're the luckiest.
So it's,
it's calibrating all of that.
I think I would have done that.
But you know,
we always say we're grateful for it because it gets you where you are grateful
for,
for whatever things you had to go through that you did or didn't do.
The notion of regret is it's not that it's pointless,
but you know,
it's sort of like that gets you to where you where you are.
Yeah.
Good advice.
Good advice for anybody.
Uh,
Laird,
what advice would you give your 30 year old self?
Stop drinking now.
Oh my God.
Stop drinking ranking now.
Stop drinking right now and patent all your ideas.
Good advice.
They go together well too.
Yeah.
Right now.
Father,
your pants and your drug also got a messy.
Yeah,
good.
That is good advice.
Uh,
Brian,
when Faye,
what do I hear?
30 I think patient.
Be patient.
Be patient,
be more patient.
And what if,
what if your 30 old self was like,
fuck that.
Why should it be a patient?
Well that's why.
Yeah,
you don't
understand.
Just be patient.
And you know,
I,
I think I was in a,
in a,
in a big rush at 30,
you know,
I'm 40 now and so it's like decades gone by and it's like,
if,
you know,
I am so,
I mean,
I'm like,
wow,
like being like I'm so much more patient now and there's much more work to be
done,
but it's like,
it's just when it's piecemeal and it's,
it's this just,
okay.
It makes so much more sense.
When you're putting stuff together,
what has helped you most to become more patient?
Um,
honestly,
the experience and the relationships that I have,
the relationships that I used to have versus what I have now.
Wow.
Like it's just better inputs.
It's not even better written puts,
they're just,
they're real people.
This is real life.
This is really real.
Like,
you know,
I mean I have a wife that is just amazing,
that understands me and on a level that it's like,
hey,
you need to do your thing.
You need to do it.
But you know,
I support it.
Like go,
like,
again,
like I have crazy behavior,
like,
you know,
like get fixated on things that I'm doing and it's like she,
she's like,
she may not get it,
but she gets it,
you know?
And,
and,
and why that's so hard to come by when you're 30,
like I didn't know I didn't date girls well and that,
that was my problem.
Yeah.
Maybe that it was like I wasn't patient enough to date girls when I was 30 or to
be involved with women that I was at 30 that understood.
Stuff like that.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
you know,
and,
and to be involved with people and women like that is,
is truly a blessing.
So eight patients is definitely the big one.
At 30.
What about me?
Yeah,
I would,
uh,
I would have told myself
start
meditating.
It's not just for hippies to play the didgeridoo start sitting down.
Rick is actually Rick Ruben.
It's one of the,
the he and another friend.
I was just going through a very Yang,
anxious,
rushed,
like aggressive period where I had a short fuse and was just in a rush to get
everything done.
And,
uh,
spoke with two close friends.
One is chase Jarvis,
worldclass photographer,
amazing guy.
And uh,
he was like,
you know,
maybe you should try TM transcendental meditation.
There are many types of meditation.
And then I was like,
ah,
1500 bucks to get a mantra.
No thanks.
That sounds like a cult.
And then,
uh,
then I had coffee with rec and he's like,
have you ever thought about TM?
And I'm like,
God damn this Tmr I fun.
Uh,
but just,
uh,
I would've said there,
there are many,
I worry with these hypotheticals of screwing up,
like causing an unintended butterfly effect in the past I'm like,
no,
I wouldn't have changed anything.
I'm not sure I want to change anything,
but the,
I,
it's hard for me to see how taking 20 minutes first thing in the morning to
meditate would have produced any bad results for me.
That aspect of it do your
patients.
Yeah,
exactly.
In that book that Laird talks about,
if you're the natural born heroes,
natural born heroes,
if you're,
if you're hunched forward,
well first
of all,
if you're hunched forward,
you go into fight or flight,
right?
You have a physiological response.
And now that we're all on our gadgets,
we're all perpetually in a,
in a,
in this position.
So it creates anxiety
and we're not in our predatorial,
we're not looking at,
we're not looking around.
So we were in this position and then we're,
we have an instinctual thing to know what's going on around us and we don't
while we're doing it.
And that just grinds on her.
We're actually putting ourselves,
um,
unknowingly in positions physically that are also creating an emotional response
that one of them being anxiety and angst because we're not living fully or
closer to our natural state really should be in.
Totally agree.
I've been trying to take time every day at the very least,
even if I'm doing a lot of writing,
because I also think that,
uh,
we're gonna find a lot of visual problems,
with,
with people who were only focusing between eight and 12 inches all day long.
So I try to get on glasses and just focus on things in the distance and really
take in those solar gazing nettle be you could work on that.
That would really help your vision.
We can distill that down.
But you know what you're talking about meditation and when,
when you know,
you come home,
you do that program because his whole thing is about meditation.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
at the end it's all these drills and be the ice man,
but it's ultimately about meditation.
Yeah.
I want to get,
I want to get read on the show at,
and it's so much trickle,
it's a mechanical meditation.
It's not,
it's not this,
it's not a swami kind of ethereal thing where you're like trying to grab
something in space.
This is mathematical.
Yeah.
And He,
uh,
he's first one to say,
I don't have the answer.
And you know what?
This guy's going to be better at it than me.
And it's okay.
It's great.
You'll love it.
Yeah.
He feel amazing.
All right,
let's go.
And that's,
that seems like wow.
And competitive out here again,
day.
We're going to do the best we can.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
That's great.
I have to check them out.
So if you guys could make,
this will be last question before we,
I just ask where people can find everything in you're all up to,
but Brian,
if you could make one ask of the people listening more one record or one ask or
recommendation,
what would it be?
Um,
I honestly,
it's like,
what were you asked in the,
um,
you know,
sauna is like,
what,
what do you,
what's tickling your fancy and it,
and it's the Bree,
you know,
the breathing,
it being more aware of your breathing because the all,
quite honestly,
it's exactly what Gabby just brought up and we were just talking about is when
you're in,
you can't breathe correctly.
When you're here,
when you're collapsed,
when you're clicking as a position.
That's basically more or less with Kelly and I have really worked our careers at
is,
you know,
it's about position and what your,
the way you move is w I understand what you're saying.
Like I see what's going on inside.
Don't,
you know,
you can't lie to me at this point.
You know?
And so I think for me,
ultimately it's about breathing.
And,
and honestly that's,
I would never have arrived at the meditation thing had it not been for the
breathing and it,
and it being like,
this is fun.
Like I'm having a blast seeing what I get out of this and how I feel after doing
this and going through this stuff.
And I think if people really were willing to figure,
see that stuff,
you know,
I it to take the time to do that,
it takes a couple of weeks and then you're like,
wow,
this is really something like I have not thought about regardless of what the
breathing is.
Right.
Where would you suggest someone start with that?
I honestly think people should start with Wim Hof.
Yeah,
Wim Hoff method.
Uh,
Google it,
you go take it.
It's a cheap course for 10 weeks.
Um,
of course,
you know,
we're tweaking and playing with other things and you know,
that's what we do.
But I honestly think the guy,
and we'll probably get them out here at some point.
It's doable.
It's very doable.
Very doable.
You know,
I,
I spam.
Yeah,
look him up guys.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
I have to sit in the ice.
Right.
You know,
I think it starts there.
And even through that with cold showers,
the fact is is it's like,
I don't care if you're a crossfitter,
if you're a professional athlete and some other sport,
if you don't breathe right,
your,
you've got a fault going on,
you've got something going on and you can expand upon it and you can understand
much more.
And it was,
you know,
like I said with the Eckhart Tolle a thing,
it's like Eckert's thing is the breath,
the breath,
because the breath is now,
there's nothing after that.
You're not thinking about the past.
You're not thinking about the future.
You're focused on what's happening right now.
Well,
the butt and the breadth and the spirit are as one because that's when the
baby's slapped on the button.
So 40 breaths with consciousness.
My mom said that exact same thing to me.
But when the breath leaves,
the spirit leaves.
Yes.
I mean that's the breath is the spirit,
the breath of life.
Yeah.
So Gabby,
what would,
uh,
what would your ask or recommendation be?
Well,
I,
I asked that everyone,
you know,
I always say that we only appreciate our health when we don't have it.
And I think,
you know,
through injuries and things,
I've learned to,
uh,
appreciate my health.
But I think if,
you know,
sort of besides your friends and family that the most important thing to cover
it and take care of is your self even it's just to the best of their ability.
Like if you're not walking today,
go walk.
You know,
if you're,
if you're still smoking,
you know,
smoke less.
Like it's not about get it all done all at once,
but just finding a way to make that a real priority.
Um,
and then my ask would be,
I always say that I'll go first.
And so that means if I'm,
uh,
checking out at the store,
I'll say hello first.
If I'm coming across somebody,
make eye contact,
I'll smile first.
That I people would experiment with that and their life a little bit.
Um,
being first be first,
because not all times,
but most times it comes in your favor.
But then the response is pretty amazing.
Like you'll see somebody,
I was at the park the other day with the kids.
Oh my God,
her hurricane harbor.
It's like hell.
And there was these two women a little bit older than me.
We couldn't be more different.
Right?
And I walked by him and I just looked at him and smiled.
This smile came to their face.
So instantly they're ready.
But you have to go first because now we're being trained in this world.
Nobody's going first anymore.
So for me,
it's like take care of yourself because that also helps you go first sooner if
you feel pretty good and go first.
Laird,
while they,
that's not fair.
They went first.
They did,
they did.
They did steal some good kick their breath and they went,
you know,
and I think part of,
I think,
I mean,
I of course the breath is,
you know,
that that's,
that's,
so that's,
that's our food.
That's what we get when we don't eat.
And that's are the breadth of life and you know,
and going first and cherishing the temple.
Uh,
you know,
I mean,
and I,
and I think what Gabby said about going first leads to where what I think too,
and I think in the,
and again,
quoting the,
my latest favorite book,
natural born heroes,
but the compassion that I think compassion is,
is exercise compassion every day.
If you could actually go out and just exercise some form of compassion,
uh,
no matter what it be,
I think that's some powerful stuff.
I think it would be a different world if people win.
And,
and,
and we're compassionate.
And I have to remind myself,
and that's a,
that's an ass.
But that's also a do for me.
I'm asking myself to do it.
Um,
and I,
and again,
I use that as,
you know,
what's good for the goose is good for the Gander,
which is,
you know,
ask of your,
what you want of yourself.
And then I think it's probably what,
you know,
it's like,
I like standup.
I like foiling.
I like this,
you know,
I like the breathing.
Other people will like it too,
you know?
So the mines the,
I think I'm the one with the compassion.
It seems like going first as a,
as a good
small step in that direction.
I think the most important thing from all of us would be don't do it.
It's about each person doing it their way,
that discovery,
not oh,
Laird's way.
Or Brian's where Gabby's where Tim's way it's about,
does any of the conversations spark you to motivate you to find your way because
that is the right way for you?
Definitely.
Um,
I don't believe that any of us believe in saying this is the way.
I mean certainly breathing,
it's hard to get around it,
but ultimately when do you do it?
How do you want to do it?
Whatever that is.
How do you want to eat whatever outside inside exercise.
But it's really more about you've got to put energy into finding your way.
Do you want it?
Cause we're talking about emotional things,
but his,
his physical,
hers emotional compassion,
but,
and then just drink more liquids,
hydration,
drink more water.
You know,
Aaron Wald,
it's the,
this all goes to you can you just said it's like be an experiment.
We've gotten so far away from that and I think this is where science has really
let us,
because science has really gotten far off in the fact that everybody in science
is trying to prove themselves right.
And that's not what science is.
Science is not about proving yourself,
right?
Science is about learning something new.
And that is if you aren't willing to experiment and learn it your way,
that's how it's going to make sense.
Like,
and it's like you don't just try whims way.
Like I have like seven different yoga breathing techniques in at this point,
which isn't just,
you know,
radical,
but it's like that's where it's led to.
And you know,
he's Laird's done it as well.
And it's,
you know,
that's the thing is being experiment so that you understand what works and what
doesn't,
not what some paper is telling me.
And also,
I mean,
what's,
what's really inspired me hanging out with,
with all of you guys,
uh,
is that another way of looking at experimentation is playing.
Like you guys have an element of play that I think many people lose as soon as
they graduate from high school or college.
They tried it that one room playing.
Yeah.
And I appreciate that.
Well and also late play not be so destructive because sometimes we have a
tendency as we get older too,
to make our play become more of a distress.
Vegas baby.
What I'm saying,
more job but our play because stop drinking and you now have a destructive
process and it's like what I said about Wildman and I said about every single
guy and I guarantee you your trainer Yup.
Has retained his youthful enthusiasm.
Definitely.
They both play all the time.
Exactly.
If you had the mom's time and trees,
yeah.
Then I guarantee you did they review date and it's about red tension of your
youthful enthusiasm that that's really about what it's about,
right?
It's having fun and that spirit of that child is what will lead you to be an
older child.
Yeah.
You'll be,
you'll be older,
young,
but you'll be young,
be young.
Uh,
this is great.
I want to close with just asking each view where we can learn more about what
you're up to,
your work and so on.
So Brian,
uh,
there's about seven on the,
on the internet or self addressed stamped envelope to no,
I,
I think the easiest way to get a hold of me is through,
uh,
or,
or find out more about what we're doing is through athletes self,
which athletes l.com which is going to probably try to spell that athlete cell.
So athlete and then c e l l like a year and a cell block got um,
that it,
you can get ahold of me there or you can find out with our training and
information,
stuff like that.
Um,
I'm most active on either Twitter or Instagram.
Like I will act of it.
Get active with people on Twitter who behave and what are your,
uh,
what's your handle?
Uh,
at I am on scared.
She's also tattooed on his knuckles,
tattooed on the knock and see it in the four hour body trailer.
It's just another way of me saying I'm going to deal with humility today.
Can I deal with fear?
Uh,
and,
and so it's just a constant reminder.
So,
uh,
that those are both my handles for that.
Um,
and I'm,
I'm pretty active on there,
so.
Cool.
Huh?
Okay.
Yeah,
I am on scared on both Twitter and Instagram.
Yes,
Gabby?
Uh,
well I have a site [inaudible] dot com but most of my energy right now is that
just for people who aren't good at spelling.
B,
y,
r e c e I know who's re spelled with a c a.com.
But most of my,
my energy right now is in,
um,
I developed a curriculum called high JAKKS and it's Hig h x.
And so there's a high x training.com and uh,
which is no joke.
Yeah,
check,
check it out,
guys.
Leaves do well.
But there's a community fun aspect kind of to it.
But um,
I mean anyway,
so I'm putting a lot of my energy into that at the moment.
So that's my been my main focus.
And how can people,
I'm like,
I am active on Instagram and Twitter,
which it'll be funny when you get to Laird,
it looks less,
less,
less frequent.
He's smart about that.
You're the smartest of us all.
Honey.
I,
Gabby Reese,
G A B,
B y r e e c e on,
on Twitter and Instagram and,
and um,
and if you want to know anything about Laird on his Facebook,
I'll tell you what we,
we posted for him in the last few days.
He's a,
he's so funny.
He's like,
I don't,
I don't understand.
Like you're telling me this is more valuable than like the actual doing.
And I'm like,
oh,
secretly it's becoming that way in the world
we live in.
You know,
I just,
I will,
I will say,
and maybe this is me being delusional,
I think that I think that the doing stolen most important.
Yeah.
And if you least having fun,
but the social media,
the showed them social media can,
can add velocity if you to something that is already going in the right
direction.
But the doing the doing is still,
I take heart like you look at,
say Rick,
you want to see inactive social media.
Look at Rick Rubin's stuff.
I don't even think it was one tweet.
He doesn't even talk to his friends.
That's true.
So the doing can still,
you can still sort of stand on the merit,
but the social media stuff can definitely add a add velocity,
uh,
at speed.
So Laird,
where can people find,
you can find your stuff.
Pacific
[inaudible] dot Org
Pacific ocean.org [inaudible] Dot Org Oh,
you have Laird hamilton.com.
Yeah,
I've Laird Hamilton.
I have layered standard life layered live lyrics.
Stand up,
stand up.com.
That's Laird La Ird,
not lar.
D,
Not Lard or l.
People
go,
they're like,
what's your name?
Layered Larry.
No Laird Lard.
He's like,
you know,
yeah.
Amazing art in coffee.
I just let him go.
I had a guy call me Larry for about three years.
I didn't even see,
I didn't even tell them why would I ruin his pop his buzzer bubble.
No.
And then uh,
but you could see some of this.
The other stuff like uh,
uh,
are the latest,
we just redid the site on a golf board.com.
So that's,
that's board golf.
ford.com is a,
is a,
is our,
is our company that we started that's just exploding right now.
The golf boards are taking over the golf courses,
like standup a is taking over the ocean,
but Laird sand up and,
and then you will use,
or do we still have our joint stuff?
No learning.
Gabby,
Gabby and [inaudible] dot com yeah,
all our health and fitness stuff is,
is all free.
It's on
Gabby Ga,
bby and layered Lai r d.com.
Cool.
And we'll put all these links in the show notes guys.
So if you missed anything or lost something and your note taking,
you can check out the show notes and links and so on a four hour work week.com
forward slash podcast.
Guys,
this is awesome.
Thanks so much.
I'm going to come back.
I don't want to be one of them.
Survived it all the time.
And you're like why he was there once.
Yeah.
She used to tell guys in a row was more than once.
So I uh,
I hope to come back and just worked him.
You're the man you should get yourself to another test.
I did and I think I'll need a long nap this afternoon.
Yes.
Making shoes,
shirts pretty soon.
X P T I survived.
I can't wait.
I this is,
this is fantastic.
Everybody check out what they're out to.
Say Hi to them on the interwebs.
Be Nice and play until next time.
Thanks for listening.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
Your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world and here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world,
we'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim,
that's athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important.
It will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me,
just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.